hello
my name is joshua benjio and
i had a lab in montreal
that is really interested in the next
generation of deep learning and today i
want to tell you about a research
program
on a new tool for machine learning that
we call g flow nets which we think can
have a fairly significant impact on
um the next generation of
tools that we can use to
um
optimize discover
search um in an interactive way
so first let me tell you a few words
about black box optimization and and
black box exploration which is slightly
different
imagine that we have access to an
expensive oracle um think of
experiments that are being done in the
real world maybe with some user
and um let's say that this each time we
do an experiment in this environment we
get an answer y
and to make life easy for us let's say y
is a number
and um we can control the experiment by
choosing x so we can think of what the
environment does is computing a function
f of x and giving us the answer but we
don't have access to f so it's black box
we don't know how it's structured
however we can query it so x is a query
and we're not going to be able to
call
query f many times
so we have to be very efficient in our
use of that resource
depending on the kinds of applications
we may also be able to send a bunch of
queries in parallel so we can have a
batch of queries b
and
what we're trying to achieve is
find a set of
queries a set of x's
whose
outcomes y
is large and you can think of them as
finding the modes of the function f
so this could be used for discovering
what to recommend
this could be used to discovering new
drugs new materials
and even in
my basic research program on causality
and system 2 deep learning which i won't
have time to talk about today
to help
do something fundamental there which is
discovering good explanations for the
data in the form of
causal graphs
in any case i'm going to focus on how we
could do this today
and
i'm going to tell you that optimization
here is maybe
not sufficient and we want to think
about how a sequence of queries can
efficiently explore the space of
possibilities
especially if we can have batches of
queries happening in parallel we want to
make sure that the queries in each batch
are sufficiently diverse
so this is connected to active learning
active learning is a very old idea in
machine learning that says that instead
of receiving the data passively the
learner can choose
or have an influence on the examples
that it's going to get
so
um
we still have this notion of an oracle
that we can query but when now we're
going to learn a function that
approximates the oracle so maybe we have
a loss function as usual
in classical active learning
we are going to do this
um by choosing the experiments x the
queries uh from a fixed
set that is not too large so think of a
set of unlabeled examples and we're
going to
ask our oracle to provide the answer
that we would get for these examples
um and we're going to do this through a
number of iterations so at each stage we
ask one or more questions to the oracle
by picking an example from the set
and then we get answers and now because
we have more data about the relationship
between x and y
we can train
that uh predictor small f
um
now an interesting question is how
should we pick those queries
and one of the really important ideas in
active learning is
uh we should pick those queries taking
into account not just
the value that our predictor gives
but how
certain we are about
the predictions that are being made by
our learning system keep in mind that a
machine learning system is imperfect it
learns from the finite amount of data
using finite computation and so it's
going to make errors
and so the uncertainty that i'm talking
about you can think of the amount of
error so if there are
experiments for which queries
for which
our current predictions are unreliable
then you know
it it's likely that these would be good
places to look to do more experiments to
get rid of that entropy to get rid of
that uncertainty
so so that's the idea of active learning
now there is a practical problem that um
my talk today
will
uh address
and that is
in practice in many applications of
interests like the ones i mentioned in
the beginning
the set of queries
s is huge it's maybe infinite or it's
combinatorial there's exponential number
of possible questions you could ask
so i can't just try every
prediction
over all the possible
queries in my set it would just take too
much time
so so this whole procedure is not
applicable in that case unless
you have a smarter way of
guessing questions instead of picking
them from a fixed set we may
want to use a
generative model
that can sample that can invent that can
imagine experiments uh queries questions
right
so so this is the setup now it's a
little bit different
uh we still have the real world the
environment on the right hand side and
we're still going to make queries and
get the answers and and sort of append
them to our data set that you see in
orange the disk there
and and we still have a
model of the world that's the f uh small
f that i had in my previous slide that
tries to approximate y given x so that's
like standard supervised learning
the new thing is how we get those
queries uh previously i said somebody
gives us a long list and we can just try
all of them
in imagination that is uh using our
model not the real world and then look
at the ones that are most promising or
most uncertain
and send them to the oracle the real
world but we can't do that because the
space of possibilities is too large
so what we're going to do is we're going
to train the second machine learning
model on the left that's the child with
imagination
and
its job is to be able to generate new
questions new configurations so you know
generative models have been around for
a while um you know with pretty
important successes in the last decade
in deep learning
uh for example to synthesize new images
can we use them to synthesize questions
um in order to obtain a better
predictions and
understand better how the world works
so that's that's the kind of thing i
want to talk about
now how are we going to train this
generative model
is by um
interacting uh by a kind of uh
interaction loop between the generative
model and the real world because while
we're training the generative model it's
also you know machine learning so it
needs to be trained
um we don't want to use the real world
that's too expensive we can't afford to
do that so we're gonna
we're gonna train that uh imagination
machine
in our mind
if i can say so right uh we're not gonna
do the actual things until we're ready
the generator is
good to go and and produce
good questions
so there's this loop between the
imagined experiments and the imagine
outcome to train the generator and once
it's trained then it's it's ready to
produce
these queries that in real world um the
environment
to provide us with more data that is
going to be useful to our task all right
that's the
general schema here what we're trying to
achieve
now
um there is a classical mathematical
probabilistic way to do this
um we can think of the function computed
by our uh
model uh is uh like an energy function
like a a reward function
and
uh in a good criterion to generate
questions here
that cover all of the
interesting uh high values of of this uh
environment
uh in a diverse way would be if we could
convert that model into
um
samples
that happen to cover the modes of that
function that happen to be high in all
of the high places or as many as
possible
of this underlying function and monte
carlo markov chain methods have been
designed to do exactly that
um given an urbanized probability
distribution or an energy function which
is the same
they can
asymptotically through this chain of
small changes
they can
eventually
obtain samples
that that cover all the loads that that
capture the
distribution that sample with
probability proportional to the
animalized function that that we're
we're given
but there is a snag the mcmc methods
work well in many applications but in
many ai setups where we are in high
dimensions and the modes of the function
are far apart think about categories
um like cats and dogs are quite
different and you know a chair is even
more different
uh it turns out that when those
categories those modes are far from each
other
multi-color markov chains in a high
dimensional space multi-color markup
chains can take forever
to properly sample from the space so so
the these approaches have
not been really used in ai very much for
for this kind of purpose
um
so what i'm going to talk about today is
an approach we call g flow nets
which allow to do that and avoid the
very long
um iterative sampling scheme that you
have in multicolor markov chains
um and but they have the same
basic properties that if we're given a
function here i call it a reward
function
and
it's going to basically convert that
you're going to train a model that's
going to generate samples
with probability
proportional to that reward function so
it converts a function that is
how well am i doing
into a machine that imagines new
configurations
and generates them so that the the ones
that produce more
reward you know you're doing well are
going to happen more often but this is
different from optimization methods
which are happy to find just one
solution that that gives a high reward
instead this
just like mcmc would try to find
all of the modes or as many as possible
okay and and if you if you sample this
many times you would get many different
uh coverage of all those modes um and if
you're trying to do like discovery of
something you don't want to just focus
on one solution you want to
explore all the solutions so that's why
at the beginning i said it's not just
black box optimization
that i'm interested in here i'm
interested in black box
exploration to discover
new solutions to problems we have
all right
so so what is a g flow net it's it's a
fairly
new way of thinking um
uh
about learning how to
generate something how to sample
a configuration that makes sense if you
want to
generate a an object that's
compositional that you know you could
construct that object through a sequence
of steps
you can think of g phonetics as a
particular kind of reinforcement
learning methods
uh but instead of maximizing which is
what
rl is trying to do which it may not
produce as much diversity as we want
is trying to sample in proportion to the
reward
so
the mathematical formalism here
uh considers all the possible ways that
you could generate
um an x so we think of an x as an object
like a molecule
or a sequence of words
um that we can generate through a
sequence of steps
and there may be many ways of producing
the same query the same x the same
question corresponding to different
paths in these sequence of actions
so that's what the
directed a secret graph on this
um slide represents
and
mathematically we think of it like in a
flow network you think of like water
flowing from a root node which is where
you know we always start from
and ending up in a sink note and
learning the g-flow net amounts to
finding how much water should go in all
of the arcs there
okay
so
there is something
uh more general here than what i'm
talking about this
idea of converting
assembling machinery like monte carlo
mark of chains that doesn't involve
machine learning as such
into a problem in training
like a deep net that can do the java
sampling
and
you know the reason why
people have not been using mcmc in many
cases as i said because
sampling might take just too much time
to get good samples uh exponentially
exponentially long time in fact
so you know is there any reason to think
that this approach of
learning to sample
which we call an amortized generator
might work better
in principle if the distribution that we
are trying to sample from is arbitrarily
complicated then there is no hope that
we can do better
but if there is structure like these
modes
for example here
you see you have these three modes three
regions where the function we we are
interested in is high
and and the learner has already found
examples from these three regions
but now
it needs to explore and and kind of
guess other places where the function
might be high that haven't been visited
yet
so
in principle in a high dimensional space
like the number of places you could try
is so huge that this is a hopeless thing
that's what i mean by intractable and
exponential time
but if those modes are arranged in a way
that is structured and the learning
algorithm can discover that structure
then we are in business then we can turn
something that looks intractable into
something that is tractable
so in the example here which is of
course a toy example you can see that
the three modes we have discovered line
up on a grid
on three of these intersections
and so the learner might guess oh maybe
there is something on this fourth
intersection that you know
we haven't visited yet so so that's what
i mean um by
um
you know taking advantage of the power
of generalization in particular this is
a form of what we call
system materialization researchers in ai
these days are very excited about how do
we generalize
far from the data in a way that's
meaningful
okay
so
in general there is no free lunch but
here
we could be lucky if the
underlying
function that we're trying to discover
has a structure
has regularities that machine learning
can take advantage of which is why we're
doing machine learning on the data in
the first place
then we might be able to
produce those samples to explore the
environment to explore potential
solutions
much more efficiently than if we use the
traditional
and cmc methods okay
so so that's for motivation
um now
my team and i have been working on the
mathematical foundations of
this this g-flowness um and i'm i'm not
going to explain uh all that in in much
detail
um
except to say that um it's related to
reinforcement learning as i said
um but it uses a slightly different
formalism
um where we think of these trajectories
as the
objects of interest for uh probability
uh modeling
and
by thinking about it in this way we come
up inspired by this analogy with flows
in a flow network
we came up with
conditions and a training objective
that will guarantee that we can if we
train a function that predicts how much
flow should go through each edge and
each node of this
um flow network
that this function will
correspond to a proper flow
and the condition is very simple and
intuitive it says that the amount of
flow coming into
a node s prime here
which corresponds to an intermediate
stage in the construction of a candidate
um
is equal to the amount of flow coming
out to all the possible next states
and we can design an objective function
sorry here
there's an objective function which
basically is penalizes for the mismatch
between the amount of flow coming in the
state as t and the amount of flow coming
out of a state st so the f hat here is a
new net is something you can train and
and the
loss function right here is something
you know we can compute the derivatives
of so we can train that neural net to
predict how much flow should be going
through each edge
um and then we can prove that
if we can train that neural net properly
then
it has the right property that
if you
um if you travel in the flow network
according to with
at each stage
making a transition to the next state
with a probability that is proportional
to the flow
on the outgoing edge
so
that's the conditional probability of
going to some next state given the
previous state
um
then what you get are samples
that show up with probability that's
what you want that is equal to the
reward uh with normalized right so
proportional to the reward function
so that that was the that's the main uh
property here that we wanted
um but but then like
unexpectedly it turns out that this
formalism also opens the door to many
other goodies for
probabilistic modeling uh in particular
um
if we make these flow networks are
conditional
we can use them for
calculating things that seem intractable
sums over an exponential number of
possible
candidates for example
if
let's say
we think of a candidate like a graph or
a sequence
and we ask
well what's the probability of all the
graphs or all the sequences that are
continuations of that sequence or that
graph that extensions of that sequence
or that graph
um well it turns out we with the neural
net we can get an answer
uh by a simple call to the neural net
um so so we can we can do what's called
marginalization or compute what's called
free energies
and with that we can compute
things that
people um you know find very difficult
in principle to compute
uh like entropies and mutual
informations
um now of course
again you know going back to this slide
about the free lunch
um this is assuming we can train the
neural net which
uh assumes that well we have enough
compute power enough
enough um
a big enough network
uh but also that there is structure that
the
underlying function we're trying to
capture
enables generalization
and in that case
we would be able to compute all these
goodies
um
yeah let me let me uh also mention
something
practical which is
you know going beyond the application to
converting
a reward function or an energy function
into a generative model
one question i guess i get is well but
what if i don't know the energy function
the reward function i only have data
right
so so then what you could do
is train the energy function
and and
in principle we know how to do that
there is a classical recipe for
computing the gradient in an energy
based model
which is the equation that's written
there
and the problem with that equation is
that it requires
sampling from
the distribution that corresponds to the
energy function and in general we can
use monte carlo markov chain mcmc to do
that but it's intractable it doesn't
work very well and so people don't use
this approach
but now if we are able to sample from
the distribution at least approximately
corresponding to the energy function we
could train the energy function in other
words if you give me some data
uh x um
i can and in our case this would be the
input output pairs x and y or it could
be you know any any kind of data that we
want to model
um
this approach uh would allow to learn a
joint distribution an energy function
between those variables
um taking advantage of the sampling
capability
of the g-flow net
now let me bring up
a
an ingredient that i haven't really
discussed much up to now
i said at the beginning
that we would like
to
query
configurations experiments
that are going to give us a lot of
information so what does that mean
and and i talk about uncertainty and
error right so where does my predictor
make errors
so
the
total error that that a a supervised
learning predictor is making
can be decomposed into two parts one we
call
epistemic uncertainty and the other
aliatoric uncertainty so these are big
words to say two things that are pretty
straightforward so the alliatoric
uncertainty is the part of the
prediction error
which has nothing to do with our model
it just has to do with the fact that
there's some in predictability in the
data like you know there is only so much
the best you could do even if you were
um
if you knew the true
model of the data the true uh generative
distribution you would still make errors
because there is noise right so
electronic concern d is just noise
there's unpredictability
and we can't do anything about this in a
way we want to you know kind of ignore
it here
when we're trying to acquire information
about
um an environment about our our world
um
we care about epistemic uncertainty so
that's the rest that's the part of the
error that we're making
which is due to our learner due to the
fact that our learner didn't have enough
data
uh that it didn't have enough capacity
that we didn't train it enough or
whatever
okay so that's epistemic uncertainty
epistemic you know has to do with
knowledge
so there's been a lot of work in machine
learning to trying to estimate epistemic
at something if you train a machine
learning predictor
how much confidence can you have in it
or actually more precisely
uh what part of that confidence can you
reduce
in particular you would like to know the
epistemic uncertainty
at a particular point to because those
points where you have a lot of
uncertainty
uh you might want to query so this is
illustrated in the figure here
and this is taken from um
standard
uh discussions uh around what's called
bayesian optimization
which are about
this
question of
where we should query
if
we can estimate the uncertainty the
epistemic uncertainty so one way to
estimate epistemic uncertainty is the
bayesian approach where we say
well
really it's not just like there's one
predictor that could fit the data
there's a whole lot of predictors that
could flip the data so in the figure we
have these three data points in red
and the blue sausage
represents all of the functions we think
could fit the data and are consistent
with our prior
and maybe the the
average of them is the blue
prediction
but maybe the true one is the which we
don't know of course is the uh black
dotted thing
so
you know where the sausages is wide uh
is is probably a good place to query
that's what we're saying and and then we
can use different methods to estimate
the width of that sausage which is the
which could be for example the variance
of our
basic variance of that predictor uh at
that point
okay so we've been applying these ideas
in the context of discovering new
molecules
um
and um and it seems to work quite well
so we've compared with mcnc methods
we've compared with reinforcement
learning method in particular what's
called ppo
and
what these graphs show is that
we are able to discover these high
scoring molecules
faster than than the more standard
methods but more importantly the
diversity of the solutions that we're
getting is much larger
um so in the middle we have the number
of modes found and that's kind of a good
metric of diversity like number of
really different solutions that are
found and you can see
the um bold
solutions which is using our g-flow net
approach that
rises up to covering more of the modes
faster
so so that's really exciting um and and
i think that
is it's just the uh beginning of um
a way to apply machine learning that's
more focused on
how the learner interacts with uh their
environment
um
and how that changes the dynamic of uh
you know how we design uh these these
machine learning systems the classical
act of learning that i've been talking
about
is good but but it doesn't scale to
those complex spaces where the the
queries the x the inputs are
high dimensional and complex so
this is
what
the approach that i talked about here
really enables
and um you know i'd be happy to answer
questions um either
uh later or you know
through email so thanks for your
attention